day six of the election campaign I'm
here in the southwest of England was
going to talk about house building
important policy on that released today
but no bigger issue a memo purporting to
describe a conversation between nicola
sturgeon and the French ambassador
basically suggesting that she would
prefer David Cameron as Prime Minister
despite publicly saying she'd only
support the Labour Party in
international government what's going on
Nicola Sturgeon the SNP totally denies
the Consul General a France Edinburgh
also said it wasn't true such story over
well labour argue whatever the truth of
some conversation in the conversation
did happen of some sort between those
two women whatever the truth of it
actually there's a fundamental reality
which is that the SNP strategically and
long-term would want a conservative in
number ten because that helps them make
the numbers for independence eventually
so whatever the truth this argument will
now be prosecuted at leaders debates in
Scotland next week and at the challenges
debate the week after it may just have
got dirty not construction destruction